the Joe Rogan experience Brian Collins
in Phoenix Frank Caliendo and Adam Ray
is a crazy lineup uh-huh are you gonna
spin it if they let you spin it find out
that thing's pins gonna say it's crystal
a agos hey everyone don't go to this he
said the first [ __ ] thing on my bank
hey everyone don't go to this your um
your fake feud with him is very strange
so much guys make videos about each
other oh you know he did the podcast
yesterday it was the funniest thing in
the world the most insulting one time
one time we were doing the podcast and
he was just lying there and I go be
respectful and sit the [ __ ] up and I
started talking and he just got up and
he slapped me in the crowd I was like
I'll [ __ ] kill you
and I came at him and he started when he
tried to kiss me
it was like Chris tonight yeah he's a
weirdo
yeah weirdo he's from out of space yeah
you know well SATs always say he's from
outer space there it is look look
wow he smacked you right in the face mmm
funny [ __ ] man hilarious and a
great guy too
just just a good dude I like being
around them it's fun yeah these are my
inner circles well we're all weirdos
right he's just he's a weirdo weirdo for
president minded me of what misfits we
are cuz I want to do this idea where I
was like I was gonna do this thing for
on it we're gonna come up with ways
funny ways to sell product I thought
it'd be a good way to recruit some
comics and get him a job sit around a
table and create like a marketing thing
and none of them like all the two of
them got back to me everybody else like
sorry I don't have time they're just
[ __ ] misfits misfit like you can make
real money you [ __ ] idiot Mac tired
too tired to get up too high got a show
at the Laugh Factory two hours off can't
make it that's what you're funny that's
why you're funny all right yeah that's a
lot of them yeah a lot of people are
funny because of the fact that they you
know they're impulsive that don't have
discipline and they just yeah it's part
of what makes them funny is the
self-loathing they're also wild they're
wild people they're not good at like
being disciplined and rigid and on a
schedule that they create themselves I
can't like yourself I would tell you
that my acting
I was in Jeffrey Tambor's class I'm
doing an acting thing and Jeffrey Tambor
looked to me he goes get a little
self-esteem problem huh I feel like his
second banana in general in life and
some guy goes thank God everybody looks
up at him because well he wouldn't be
funny if he didn't if you didn't hate
himself so I'll take him this way never
forgot it I was like yeah all right
that's hilarious yeah I don't know if
you have to like yourself that much I
think you should always be a little
dissatisfied with yourself III works for
me yeah I don't think you should be
satisfied very often if you want to be
good at anything
you know you're on a path right you're
on an improvement and growth path you're
trying to get better whatever it is it's
tennis right you're trying to get better
at it all the time look you shouldn't if
you want to get better at at all time
you got to be scrutinizing you can't be
happy about certain moments where you
were really good and think that's you
I've got to be thinking about the things
that didn't go good yeah I gotta fix
that part is that story whether it's
true or not but I think it is Rafael
Nadal had just won Wimbledon one of the
greatest of all time you ever see him
play like his athleticism his power he
hits the ball so hard that the ball a
camera of this is the ball revolves
twice as fast it makes it 22 many
revolutions is the average high level
tennis player that's how hard that's how
much spin it is like it's 80 versus 40
or something and he he got out and he
just won Wilton and he's back he's back
in the locker room going I know I just I
don't know if my grip should have been a
little bit I feel like it should I think
I'm gonna change it you know that it's
still adjusting everyone you have to be
yeah that's how you get to be that guy
yes and as soon as you get to be that
guy and go up I got it
then you're gonna fall off you're done
that happens - don't you feel stand-ups
that way too though you know well what
we're talking about with Kinnison right
yeah you know Kinnison when he was on
fire he was longing for acceptance and
longing for respected attention and he
was gonna take it yeah he just went out
there [ __ ] guns blazing like an
animal but then once he got he's
partying with Bon Jovi and Motley Crue
and they're doing blow [ __ ] on the
tour bus and you know drinking vodka
till 5:00 in the morning all that chaos
it's just it stops being the same thing
life is now you're celebrating the fact
that you're the
[ __ ] instead of you're desperate to make
the best work you can make desperate to
work I talked to this I won't say the
name of the famous rock'n'roll made of
Elton John but may as well be but he
made it he made it he made a seminal
album like an album that's a classic
album and I said what do think it was he
goes I was just so desperate to be heard
mmm I was desperate to be heard and then
you get older and you get rich and you
kind of prove it you can do it and you
lose the Bob Dylan talks about that
he goes I don't know who wrote those
songs like I don't I don't remember like
they said they read his lyrics back and
he said isn't that something you know
like who did that not me I don't know I
can't do that anymore
that's it that's a that's a fear of mine
I want to be I want to stay hungry
[Applause]